Kenyan Drake joining us here on the Rich
Eisen show from Miami Dolphins courtesy
of smile train how are you Kenyan Drake
are you doing rich I haven't thanked you
for coming on the show how are you
preparing for a full year a full year of
compliment of football Kenyan Drake no
we literally just stepped off the
practice field right now so we just had
a great great Thursday practice looking
for a real smooth last Friday and you
know just taking it one week at a time
honestly all right you know having fun
is okay how much of the load are you
gonna carry this year in this offense
would you say um me I will not give you
a specific number just whatever it takes
to help this team win
no okay by the way just to let you know
I don't have you in fantasy yet okay I
draft tonight but I will tell you this
though that was not a fantasy related
question that said give me give me a
number what what what on average number
of touches you think you're gonna have
this year can you drop I would hope you
know at least 15 you know running
passing you know whatever the case may
be so you know the authors rolling
really good I might know gates you know
mentioned before he wanted me you know
around 20 touches so you know there's at
least 15 you know be around my
wheelhouse and you know up from there
what's your favorite route some of your
favorite route I'm hanging with Marshall
Faulk for as many years as I have I know
that's a what you ask a running back who
likes to do more than just run what do
you like you know the funny thing is you
know I'm a you know lamb burger on me
you know we just we just take it and
taking on the nine you know oh you know
catch me if you can catch me if you can
what is Frank Gore been like to be
hanging around with Kenyan Frank is just
good testament to longevity in this in
this league he he gets in you know the
first person and I ask how literally
actually accident today because I
started noticing him coming in and
working out before too early want to
work out which is at 6:45 and I'm like
you know what time you get up there
there's already so you got to sweat in
before we even you know do the actual
official workout he's like you know I
get here in six o'clock every morning
and you know that that just you know of
Monza adds up to
how long he's been asleep doing what he
needs to do keep his body you know well
you know well or didn't you know just
throughout these years and you know I'm
looking forward to you know see how you
know what else he can bring to the table
and help this team and so is there
anything specifically you've picked up
from him on the field um well I don't
know how much you you know you study his
game or know you know exactly how he
kind of runs and maneuvers but he seen
him up you know in person he has really
the the best one of the best feet full
workout I've seen you know from a player
especially I'm running back and I was
really how you great a really good
running back you know as our as a speed
is strength obviously in contact
situations but you know and is giving in
again give even give a situation his
feet makes put them in you know the best
situation to you know make a good cut
make a good read so he has real good
feet and once he gets to that today you
know the whole you know you he sets out
his blocks well and you know you know
you just used he just uses wherewithal
is 14 years of experience and also he
still can run really good for a half
hour OD is 55 60 yes
that's what I'm looking for 55 or 60
year-old Frank Gore he is the
Inconvenient Truth Kenyan what that is
what he is so 55 or 60 I like that I
like that a lot how has Tannehill looked
Kenyan Drake can I look great you know I
feel he has this this extra hunger that
he you know that you know you need out
of your quarterback and especially with
him coming off of the last couple years
where will you know you got hurt the end
of my rookie year and we were really you
know beginning to roll and you know
after you know having you know winning
five six games in a row and you know
last year got hurt in training camp in
you know you could tell you know that
definitely it didn't really beat him
from you know being here every day doing
we needed to do make sure you know he
stood a leader of our team but now he's
on the field you know and physically
leading us you can see you know I'm you
know how bad he's going to be higher and
you know helped lead his team to we know
where we need to be so he's definitely
looking real great Kenyan Drake here in
the Rich Eisen show how did you watch
any of the harden
on HBO Kenyon you catch any of it
actually I didn't I don't have cable in
my house I just have laughs ah excuse me
say that one more time you don't have
you don't well I mean you know you're on
a show on Direct TV right now do you
need do you need help on that front no
I'm good financially it's just no no
that's not where I'm going I can give
you a hook-up is what I'm saying it's
just you know I you know I just watched
Netflix or played a video game so you
know I don't really watch a lot of TV so
what are you watching then what are you
what are you watching that actually just
started watching the office I don't know
I had never watched it from start to the
beginning so I'm like no season one
right now so it's pretty funny oh you
are in for a good one now the American
version right not the British version
you're there's a yeah I never I've never
seen a merrier I mean a British version
it's pretty good Kenya so who's your
favorite character in the office right
now so far I really I don't really have
a favorite character right now I'm still
kind of feeling a feeling filling them
all out because they're really all
awkward and there's really like it's
almost like to the point where it's like
almost uncomfortable to watch it because
all the situation is just so awkward but
that also makes me like keep wanting to
watch it because I want to see what
other courts they're so if there was a
camera on you and who would be the one
that would say the craziest things in
the Dolphins locker room that we would
then zoom in on you and you'd look at
the camera kind of like giving us that
look of like what's what's he saying who
would that be
probably like by McCamey the character
he didn't leave he leaves a charge when
it comes to that
Andre branched you know really a deeper
than general we have a lot of characters
on decent I feel like offense
we're losing Jarvis like I wouldn't say
we don't have any any outspoken
characters but we have just in terms of
the defense they we have a lot of people
who are just you know they they had that
type of personality and I feel like
often this year is a little more even
keel well that Jarvis that's where I was
going with the hard knocks
you know Jarvis gave quite a speech and
Episode one of hard knocks filled with
unmentionable words that we can't say
right here on our large simulcast
Canyon
I'm wondering how that soliloquy of his
played in your locker room yes now
jobbers was he you know Barden on one of
my favorite people to be around in
general especially on the field I would
you know go to war with him and if you
know you weren't already aware me and
him you know had a little bit of a
situation at the end of year last year
gives Buffalo to where we got kicked out
of the game for you know going a little
have a little extracurricular activity I
saw that yeah and you know between you
know like I say we both wear our our
emotions on our sleeves when it comes to
that I'm you know that's something that
I kind of had those Alina learners I you
know become you know more in this
professional realm and things like that
because obviously I don't want to you
know put a situation where I'm on the
field help my team win you know I don't
want to do that but also you know I have
innate ability to go out there and just
make plays be emotional that's just a
game and he brought that you know to
this team on another field and you know
you saw that you know I feel like he
doesn't do the same thing with you know
and obviously with the Browns because
you know it showed a hard knock so I
obviously I wish nothing but the best
for him because you know he's always
going to be a player no matter where he
is where he goes so then who's wound
tighter Kenyan Drake Jarvis Landry or
Nick Saban who's wound
tighter well can I do 1a 1b however you
wish to answer the question but I do I
do require an actual answer though
Kenyan um I feel like Nick Saban he's
he's definitely a perfectionist and not
saying Jarvis isn't but I feel like with
the you know the the leadership role as
a head coach for the Alabama Crimson
Tide he has more of say so too he can
just you know be you know go ballistic
and be that type of person that he needs
to be but then also he can be you know a
proprietor for you know comfort when you
know is interested in those games where
we're you know and you noticed in lassie
and he watched it again Louisville when
we're blowing a team out that's when
he's most active he's no I saw that all
over the place he got after somebody for
a personal foul penalty up 30 I saw that
he took Miller yeah oh yeah
I play with Kristian Miller and it's
just funny to say because he's not that
type of player but you know in those
situations you know you kind of lose
your your cool and you know Sabre will
remind you who's better at losing their
cool did you have you ever been on the
business end of one of those from Nick
oh yeah what was it what's that like um
god I just have to just just keep on
walking and you know you know use a
little shorter than everybody so he's
gotta be like right under your chin
straps you know and you're gonna feel
you're gonna feel that raise that fire
you're like right under your chin and
you just kind of had to just keep moving
and you know if he really wants you know
he'd get your chin he'll stand in front
of you then you have to kind of just
stand there and just take it and
eventually it'll be done and then you
know lesson learned
okay Kenyan Drake dolphins running back
here in the Richard show tell me about
smile train before before you head off
the organization to where they benefit
cliffs charity or their Eclipse charity
that benefit cleft lip and cleft palates
internationally and I had the pleasure
to one go up and do a fundraiser or walk
up in New York and on Long Island where
they were founded we raise money for you
know select a select you know group of
people to come up there and you know
just take take advantage of the walk
that we had and then I went to the
opportunity to go to Mexico City where I
first hand saw patients I went to
patients houses you saw their
transformation in they're not just you
know the the kid in general but the
family in general I went I witnessed
surgeries firsthand like it was it was
awesome it was definitely a great
experience so a smile train definitely
is in my eyes and a little frontier and
you know helping kids just have a better
quality of life because a smile is you
know the first impression for a lot of
people and you know first impression is
the most important impression and if you
don't have that confidence don't have
that ability to you know go out and you
know promote yourself you know as you
know as fulfilling as you want to that
could be no detriment of any type of
person so I feel like smile
train is definitely you know given
almost like a second chance to a lot of
people who you know have that you know
that affliction good for you Kenyan
Drake Smile Train org is how you can get
involved and what Kenyan Drake is
talking about all right thanks for the
call let's make this a regular thing
okay you tell coach case Rich Eisen said
I want a thousand thousand out of you
this season okay
that's the largest I won a thousand
thousand you tell coach case okay
officer I'm going to his office right
now and right now delivered a message
personally yes he's been on this show he
knows me I know him so a thousand
thousand if you want to record the video
and send it to us we'll post it we'll do
it we'll make it content we'll get it
out alright and make sure you draft me
tonight too
oh that's a given sir I'm on it I am on
that so why do you think I told you to
tell gates thousand thousand come on KD
x32 on Twitter Kenyan Drake could just
chat lady sir you bet right back at you
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience